my man hey Rich how you doing good I saw
you in the chat earlier you're talking
about Alberta what happened there
uh provincial election today so we'll
see how that rolls right right right
okay no good choices really but uh
that's where we're at today right yeah I
saw vote NDP was trending on Twitter
today and I figured that's what that was
about quite quite situation
um for those of you out there in the in
the outside of Canada world that is the
Socialist Party in Canada it's even more
socialist than Justin Trudeau's party
anyway
um what's crackalackin man what's going
on you know what talk about dichotomy uh
uh Sky there was saying dichotomy a
number of times and you had uh that with
those two last callers uh they were both
very very different and uh I have to say
um for the first one there I saw the the
the comments coming through and I'm no
simp but man when you've got a woman
stepping into the lion's den ready to
have this conversation come on this is
what it's about you want to hear what
they have to say you know what good on
the gals you know good on the gals for
putting their neck out on the line yeah
yeah yeah they're stepping in a lion
stand ready to have this chat and you
got some jackasses out there making some
comments that are just not uh productive
right so and that's part of the thing
with it's part of the game yeah yeah
exactly so one thing I was telling moth
um and seeing that initial date that we
saw
my thing is this is that it's not the if
they love you or hate you that will get
you it's the indifference
it's the indifference yeah you got to go
into a situation and walk away and if
they love you or hate you be happy with
that if they walk away not giving a damn
about you that's what you got to be
worried about yeah yeah well you know to
the guy's fault he he's he's just a nice
guy he didn't know how to deal with a
strong chick like that and you know to
be honest with you
um
you know if I was dating right now and I
and I came across a woman like that like
I just wouldn't have the time for it
like I would just basically
I would just deal with it have a good
night I mean I'm not the kind of guy
that would sort of walk off but I would
just deal with it you know have a good
knife
good conversation you know can come out
of it you know who the hell knows where
it goes but like guys just can't deal
with women like that for you know for
the most part and there's a lot of them
out there right like um
the girl before Skye was I mean she was
a tough cookie you know you could tell
you know she's you know she's had to
look after herself and um she's got
certain certain expectations although I
don't think that that the honesty about
the guy that she was looking for was
clear enough like okay you know like how
tall is he have to be okay fine okay how
much money does he have to make well it
doesn't really matter money doesn't
really matter but money matters to you
know to women right like if you like if
you're gonna have a family you at least
have to be honest about the reality of
Finance right because you can't have a
family if you don't have a guide as
financially sorted right women don't
have a lot of patience for that guys in
real life but the problem you know
therein lies is that you don't want to
come off as being judgmental especially
on you know a video like this because
it's public sort of thing and well you
know I need a guy with money well you do
need like ladies you can be honest about
that you want a guy that's got his life
sorted it's totally fine
yes you know uh solipsism and hypergamy
Springs Eternal yeah and I think those
two things have really messed up the
ladies to a certain extent and it's no
fault of their own
um like you said that's the future it's
not a bug right yes
and so then they look at that and they
they but Society has told them that they
are so right all the time you combine
that with their solipsism but they they
sincerely think what they think is good
for them is also good for you
well well this is why you'll get women
that'll that'll say you know I'm looking
for my guy I'm in my 30s you know time
is running out
um but if I don't find him that's okay
well
that may be lying to ourselves no sense
yeah right like why are we lying to
ourselves like let's just be honest you
know you want what you want
let's go get it and be intentional about
it and do it properly let's not play
games around it or you know it's it
doesn't matter or I'll just press like
the thing that women will never get
their heads around you know what I find
anyway is that they don't understand
that the pool that they're looking at
for the guys that they're after is so
small it's so minuscule uh because so
many guys are soft the week so many guys
are socially awkward they're not
calibrated they don't know how to deal
with them they don't know how to date
and then they're just like well there's
an army of guys out there somewhere like
he'll just come my way at some point if
I just will it or if I just
I just get into my energy Crystal days
or whatever that happens to be my
horoscope will tell me it will come from
you know well the guys have been pushed
down to been beta ties as well and
that's the problem that's that rough
combo that that we brought got to break
people out from it drives me a little
bit around the bed being a seasoned
gentleman
um and seeing these guys who are jacked
looking good but they got no game and
they just submit constantly uh it's it's
tough to watch and it's not full
submission they're just not willing to
put themselves out there yeah hey you
know go out there be a respectful
disrupter and and uh so if a lady says
something offside call her on it quickly
and the one jet that was called it said
yeah he was taken aback by what they say
yeah there's a lot that they say that's
out land just try and come up with
something witty and disruptive but
respectful at the same time
you know it was funny the other day I I
went down to my local uh Pub there
because gorgeous patio season now here
in Calgary sat down next to a couple
having their first I know their second
half date I wanted to watch the
basketball game turn my back so I said
you mind if I sit here he said and
jokingly he said yeah as long as you
don't talk to us we're on a date so I
said all right that's no problem
so I turned around and was watching the
game and they started talking about some
pretty lascivious things and so they
could see my my shoulders kind of Bob
because I was laughing at them and I got
right in the conversation well rich I
can tell you you know baby rabies came
up you know uh solipsism came up and
dealing with these things talk saying it
directly to this woman who is clearly
dealing with this
she thought it was hilarious she thought
it was great because I was challenging
her so much so that I asked them I said
listen guys this is your date I gotta
take off and they said no stick around
stick around you're making this
interesting yeah there you go man you
know you can do anything to woman but uh
bore her and you know that's what you
did you basically took over the
conversation yeah yeah so all right man
but give that one first woman credit
yeah yeah Ray for coming in and doing
that the guy's gonna expect themselves a
little bit and realize hey they're
coming in for this conversation that's a
good thing it's it's a great thing
thanks brother we'll talk to you later
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out